[Music]  the duffle coat is the hardest-working  piece of outer wearing in your closet  and has a cool rocker pedigree it is  British  it is preppy and his bad boy is elegant  the coolness of the duffle coat is gonna  come out got those great rope toggle  closings in that really generous hood  that goes on over a stocking cap or  fedora and that's the real sweet spot  for a lot of guys who want that kind of  rakish look  they want their shoes to be a little bit  beat up than one-third jeans to maybe  have one hole on them in the duffle coat  has kind of already got that pedigree  I think the toggle coat is the perfect  item to really help you achieve great  style for fall  [Music]  you  [Music]  you